Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about the fundamental
building blocks of hodoki. So, hodoki
are the disentanglement techniques.
That's a pretty direct translation of
what it means to disentangle or unmake a
mess of something that's all bound up.
Um, so we're going to do some hodoki
work today with Josh. Josh is back. So,
I know you guys will all be super
excited. You don't have to deal with
just me. Um, we're gonna get right to
it. Josh, let's go to work.
All right. So, let's talk about the
fundamental building blocks of hideoki
and what that is. So, hoki are simply
disentanglement techniques. So, get
disentangled from whatever you're
tangled up in. There are two types of
grabs we're going to talk about these
from. One is dodori and do is like the
core dori is to grab and that would be a
katadori, a munadori, a rioati, an rio
katadori, an edidori, right? So, any of
those grabs. All right.
in the body grabs. Basically, what Josh
is trying to do is create tension in the
grabbed spot. Right? Now, if I'm
grabbing the core of his body without
grabbing his fabric, I'm going to have a
really weak grab. Right? So, Josh just
did a triangle from this or an
insultiari, whatever he did from this,
right? It doesn't matter. Um, it's going
to be really hard for me to hold him
unless I got like big basketball player
sized hands, right? So, uh, if he just
increases the pressure there at that
spot, I'm probably going to pop off.
Okay. Now, even if I have a good hold on
the fabric, if he can make enough
tension on that fabric, he's probably
going to pop off, right? So, creating
tension at the grab spot is the first
thing you're going to do. You're going
to do that basically by extending out.
Okay? So, in some way, so let's say I
had Joshua Edidiori, right? The basic
escape he's going to do for this is come
to the outside and create tension at
that spot. So, by bringing his hand up
like he's doing and turning on it, he's
making a ton of tension right there at
where my grip is, and it's going to be
really, really hard for me to hold him.
Okay. Now, he can also do a Timmy with
this, right? So, for example, on the the
stoi we just do, he's coming here and
he's hitting me in the head here. Bang.
At the same time, right? So, he's
popping me in the head as well as as
that. If we were in a cotadori and he
did a triangle, same thing, right? He's
going to be hitting me. Bang. Okay. Now,
we're not thinking about the hit in the
sense of like it's creating so much
damage that I go I'm shocked to death
and I I fall apart or I go to sleep or
whatever. And I think when I talk about
this, a lot of times people think like I
have some kind of like pacifistic ideas
about it. No, I've just hit people as
hard as I possibly can and nothing
[\h__\h] happened, right? So you can hit
someone all out, right? And they have no
reaction. And so I think depending upon
that reaction is a bad idea, right? So
while the ATM is going to help in that,
he's not dependent upon it, but what it
is really doing is pushing my face even
further away from the action. Right? So
even if you know I'm a tough guy and he
does that triangle when he starts
pushing my face away it gets really
really hard for me to stay uh in tune
with Josh right so I can't have much har
because my my hand gets separated from
my body I can't see very well what's
going on anymore because he's in my face
so that's the quality of it and it's not
because like we're pacifists and we
don't want to hurt someone like I
recommend regularly beating people with
sticks and blades so like I can't say
that I'm a pacifist about these things
but um you also can't count on on it
being amazingly effective, right? Okay.
So, he's going to create tension at the
grab spot. He's going to at Timmy most
of the time with this and the Timmy is
is how it works out really well. And
then if those are failing, he's going to
go into some kind of principal lesson in
order to do that, right? So, one of the
kiosa. Okay. So, for example, let's say
Josh uh went to a 45 with a little uh a
little pressure, right? Okay. And he
comes up here like this and now he can't
get me off. If he comes through with Neo
right here, right? he'll weaken my grip.
So basically what all of the wrist
techniques and iikido do is they create
a weakness in inside the gripping
device. Right? So in the gripping device
is my hand, right? So when I'm holding
him, I'm really strong in this
configuration. Now if you put me in a
weaker configuration like the Niko, now
I'm not nearly as strong because my
hands all messed up, right? So like if I
was going to climb a rope and I climb
like this, that's the normal way I'm
strong. If I tried to climb the rope
like this, that's a difficult way,
right? And I wouldn't be nearly as good
at climbing rope that way. So, same
thing's true with this. He's going to go
into one of the principles. Now, on that
same 45, he could also go into an eekyo,
right? And the eeky, what the eekio is
going to do is it's going to create a
ton of pressure here, and it's really
hard for me to hold on while he's
pushing me in a vulnerable position. So,
my arm can't get as strong that way
because my elbows up, so my shoulders in
a weaker position, and it's easy for him
to pop me off, right? He could do the
same thing with, say, a sano. Maybe he's
going to go uchimari for whatever reason
on this Moro, right? And then when he
does that right here, he's got the
Sancho and he can use that Sanchko to
help clear me off as well. Right? So
he's going to A create tension at the
grab position, b give a Timmy if he can,
and and that's part of the elongation of
the the tension process. Then he's going
to apply uh some kind of principal
lesson in order to get me. Those are
probably going to either be uh Ekkyo,
Nikio, Sanio, could be a Yonko although
probably not quite as likely, could be a
Gokio, although not quite as likely, or
could be a Rokio. Right? So any those
principal lessons are going to make the
facility or the the thing that I'm using
to grab him weaker, and that's going to
make it easier for him to escape. So
those are his main main ideas. And then
of course, if all those ideas fail, he's
going to immediately go into Conrain.
He's going to go in some adaptation,
right? So let's say Josh shot a Silto
Mari on this, right? Sorry, Silto Morei.
He shot a solorene. He's creating
tension here. He's coming around. Now,
if it doesn't work, he's going to adapt
into another one there. He used a
triangle, right? So, so if all of those
fail, then he's going to immediately go
into Conrain and Conrain's um going to
change the situation and hopefully he
can get free from that situation. Now,
those are all doory, the body dory. The
hands are really not that different
except we're not going to rely upon
stress as our number one factor. So, the
reason for that being, right, if Josh
just pulls away from me here, I can
probably keep him, right? Okay. So he
really needs to in this situation create
a weakness in my hand right away because
grabbing this is easy for all of us to
get a hold of. Right? So everyone is
going to be able to hold that really
really strong. Right? So creating
tension here isn't going to work quite
as well. So what he's going to try and
do immediately is start to get one of
those basic ideas. Now he could nio,
right? He could eek you. He could kash.
He could Yeah, it's okay. He's Josh is
doing his own thing. It's okay. I can
adapt. All right. So, so, uh, he can do
any one of those principal lessons in
order to pop me off, right? Because what
he's doing is he's weakening that grip.
That's what he's doing. And again, of
course, if he can use the other hand, he
will, right? So, if I had him yak here,
he could come in with a triangle and hit
me in the floating ribs. Bang. And
that's more likely to help me let go
because I'm getting pushed further away
from that spot. So, the Teedori are in a
lot of ways harder because they're going
to have a better hold. So you're
immediately going to start using
anything from the kilowaza in order to
do that. Right? So orchokios can do it.
Right? So if I had him yakote and he
turns so mari here, bang, he's pushing
on the back of my elbow and that makes
it really really hard for me to to keep
holding on to him. Um and of course if I
adapted to that, he would adapt right
along with me and we'd get a con for it.
So those are the basic building blocks,
right? You're going to use those all the
time. If it's a doory, first you're
thinking, how do I create pressure? How
do I create a Timmy? How do I use
principal lessons? If it's a hand grab,
how do I create principal lessons?
Right? So, uh, and and the tension and
the atimmy also are all in there, but
the main thing is you're going to be
working those principal lessons. Okay?
Now, understand all this has to be done
with Tino Hinko. You can't have hideoki
without Tino. So, say we're here and
Josh just clears my hand with whatever,
right? I'm still here. So, immediately
after he clears that, I'm still going to
be hitting him, kicking him, grabbing
him, whatever I was doing before.
However, if he adds stowari to that, now
he's in a different position and I have
to adapt to him, right? So t or hoki
can't happen without tinohinko. So you
always have to add a tino. Those are the
basic six that you've seen before.
Right? So it's either going to be a 45,
a 90, a triangle, stom, an uchimori, or
an edimi, right? So those are the basic
ones we're going to use all the time.
You're always trying to increase your
position from muhani, right? Like this
to a better position, right? And the
next best position is hani. That's here.
Okay? The next best position is hitoi.
That's here. And the next best position
is edi here. So when we're getting those
hokei, that's how your line of thinking
should be going, right? So uh that's it.
That's that's that's it. Did I miss
anything? I think I got it all. Okay. So
those are the building blocks you use.
If you want to see some more specific
ideas, I'll give them to you. Um if you
look in the forms, the forms do these
things consistently. So the forms
outline all the rules that I just did.
Uh just intuitively you work through
them as you do the forms. So those are
the basic ideas. I'm Christopher Hines,
Joshua Tehi. Behind that center cam
right there is Maya Salana McGown. She
gave one of these little little waves.